Lucas:
It's like a sunset.
Of tuna.
The producers told me that I was going to be
interacting and eating sushi in some way.
The rarity, the specialness of the experience
was not conveyed and could not have been
conveyed. Here we are in Tokyo.
Just got off the plane a couple of hours
ago.
I was supposed to be on a beach in Bali, but
National Geographic called the other day and
said, uh, cut your vacation short, come to
Tokyo.
And now I don't know what the plan is going
to be.
It's a letter and it's a list of sorts,
sorted into categories.
It says Dear Lucas and a residential
neighborhood in Tokyo, Chef Hisashi Otatsu
presents an omakase menu with some creative
and non-traditional ingredients and cooking
methods that put it on our 2024 best of the
world list.
Your mission. Find out why by completing our
scavenger hunt.
Don't forget to take photos as you complete
each task.
First things first, test out the camera.
Selfie.
Mean mug. We're actually doing this now.
First is to find Utsutsu sushi.
Ride the subway to Nakameguro station.
Ride the subway.
Done. Walk along the canal and explore the
neighborhood.
Done. Bring a present to give to the owner
if you don't have one, purchase one.
Baked goods might be kind of cute.
A haircut. Maybe some tea.
Got it. I'm holding the tea underneath my
armpit.
You just can't see it.
Done. After the train tracks.
They said you'd see it when you see it.
Find that sushi.
Done. I think there's something magical when
chefs meet each other, mostly because most
chefs are so kind and so nice and know what
we go through within the industry.
But more than anything, we're also
perpetual, lifelong students.
Wherever we're eating, whatever we're eating,
whoever we're eating with huge objective of
ours is to understand the deliciousness.
I felt very much at home and at ease with
chef because he was so happy to, to teach me
things that I didn't know. This I'm sorry to
ask this, but can I take a photo of you?
Done.
I cooked in Japan a while ago in kaiseki, but
because I was very junior, I was not allowed
to touch fish. So this is like a very next
level thing for me.
As a chef, I don't think I'm ever going to
get this opportunity ever again to sit in a
restaurant with a chef and ask so many
probing questions and meet a chef who is so
open to answering those questions and
genuinely helping me understand a little bit
more about the evolution and the movement of
sushi through the ages.
Mhm. This is ridiculous.
It's so baller to start a meal with texture
that you don't anticipate when you walk
inside of such a serene omakase sushi place.
As a chef who's cooked in the western world,
you see microgreens, you get scared because
you think that it's going to be bitter.
It's going to be it's going to take things
away.
But when it's doubled down on that in the
center to such texture and the oiliness of
the fish plays with the natural bitterness
inside of those greens, it's such an
unexpected first step into a new direction.
I've never started any sushi meal like this.
First bite of the meal done.
What.
The imprint on there isn't just for show,
it's actually Smokey.
I feel like it's a call out to some of the
smokey flavors that are going to happen
later. When we look at a restaurant like
sushi, a lot of people want to throw the word
experimental and new on there.
But in our conversation with chef, one of
the most important words he said was new
tradition. So how would you describe your
style of sushi?
Learn about his cooking philosophy.
Done.
It's kind of smoke, I think.
Mhm. God damn it!
Sometimes I wish I was acting, but I
genuinely am not.
First of all, I've never had wasabi like
that before.
Why isn't it spicy?
I was reminded that that's how wasabi tastes
like all around the world.
Most wasabi that you get in takeout sushi
restaurants is actually horseradish that's
dyed green. And so it's got an
aggressiveness to it.
One of the cool things that chef did was
bring in his artisan that had made a lot of
his chopsticks table settings, in this case
specifically the wasabi grater.
So what is this? What is it for?
And why do we have to make it out of the
stingray.
Do you see that your philosophies match up?
Ask about his ingredients and tools, done.
And Udatsu san was nice enough to show us
that process and to let me try my hand at it.
Oh, it's so, um.
It's very green.
It's very vegetal.
The spice is momentary and it's exciting and
it's explosive, but it's not excessive.
Grate Fresh wasabi, done.
So I see lotus roots.
Particularly excited about this as a Chinese
chef, because there's a Chinese ingredient of
a Chinese pickled mustard greens.
But when we saw the prep of this earlier,
it's a totally different, um, color.
It's bright green instead of yellow.
I'm expecting a lot of crunchiness, a little
bit of that, like silky sliminess from the
nagaimo and importantly, the first
appearance of rice in this tasting menu.
Mhm. Wow.
I love this.
Actually out of this world.
The focus that chef has, plus the restraint
he has to bring in new elements.
There's something new going on there.
Okay, here we go. First piece of nigiri.
Chef Udatsu:
Nigiri.
Lucas:
Yummy. A beautiful thing that I learned about
sushi today is that if the fish is good, the
fish part is good, but the rice is perhaps
the most reflective of the sense of style of
each sushi chef.
What is your approach to the rice here?
It was really special that we got the chance
to see how that rice was prepared.
What you can hear now is the rice alarm,
which basically is the rice jumping up and
down inside of the pot, causing the lid to
clank.
Sushi chef Udatsu makes two types of rice,
one for maguro that's a little bit more
punchy, a little bit more acidic, and the
other for everything that's not mackerel.
It's such like minute differences.
But from the time the rice gets arrest to
the manipulation of the rice, all changes the
texture just so slightly.
So that when we're tasting it like this, it
doesn't taste like how it did with the fish.
But eventually throughout the process, it
will.
Preparing the two types of rice, done.
Something really interesting about a lot of
the things I've had today is the sequence of
flavor and the evolution, and like the
timeline within the palette.
Mhm. Like something will come in and there'll
be one texture and then there'll be like a
hidden little surprise in the middle.
So good.
In this case a sweet small burst of sweet
shrimp in the center.
I haven't seen before and I didn't know it
was possible.
Learn how to cut fish in the traditional
Japanese style.
We did not do that.
It would have been inappropriate, given how
woefully insufficient my knife skills are.
However, we did learn a lot about fish
butchery and everything to do with the fish.
One of the most amazing things as a chef
watching a sushi chef is that every single
step is so neat.
Everything is squared off.
Very aspirational stuff.
To clear the air as opposed.
I don't speak Japanese anymore.
I worked in Japan for a couple of years,
picked up a kitchen level Japanese which is
50% grunting, and then lost the 50% of
grammatical syntactical Japanese due to, uh,
an ex-girlfriend telling me that my Japanese
is bad.
Learn how to cut fish in the traditional
Japanese style.
Sort of done.
The chef also brought a second artisan.
He is the go to knife expert for all of the
top sushi restaurants in all of Tokyo.
What's incredible about that relationship is
how well he's gotten to know each chef that
he serves.
How do you talk about knives and how do you
find the right knife for the right chef?
Meet the knife guy, done.
Nothing prepared me for this.
Everything just collapses into a puddle of
maximal flavor.
The fat just melts and pushes on, which is
like into a puddle all over your palate.
Then the rice starts to come up into those
little pieces that you chew through.
Little pop pop up, up, up, too good.
Wah! The crab is really nice and sweet.
Yum. Try sushi from a company that it's not
from Udatsu Sushi as a point of comparison.
Okay, so we found a negitoro, which is a
minced tuna with chives.
Mass produced nori has this, like brilliant
green color, but it just doesn't have that
crisp, obviously, that Udatsu sushi had.
The rice doesn't have the same amount of
chew.
It's a little bit gluey.
And the fish, obviously, in order to keep it
preserved inside of a cold case, it doesn't
have the same texture and actually doesn't
taste very much like fish.
Not to say that this tastes bad.
Just doesn't compare.
Oh my goodness, I didn't take a photo.
This photo is missing but I swear I did it.
Taste the convenience store sushi done.
What? One bite.
The layers of flavor again usually when you
when I've had sushi before and we get to uni,
they always ask would you like this one or
that one, this type or that type?
This has both.
One a little bit more textural and buttery.
The other one, Punchy.
Punchy, bright and sweet.
Crisp from the fried seaweed in the middle.
And then that signature rice.
This is the part of the meal when everything
starts to blend together.
Because as the flow picks up, the rhythm
picks up.
Everything's just happening.
And all our job as customers is to try to
grasp what's happening to us
. I'm sensitive to the word fusion because it
implies a sort of crass bombardment of
cuisine and a mish mash of things in a way
that is done in pursuit of novelty instead of
pursuit of genuine deliciousness.
Whoa! I'm so sorry.
Can someone translate what's happening right
now?
Prawn roll infused into egg yolk sauce.
Is that what it is? Tradition informs chefs
evolution.
But what keeps him going is deliciousness.
And there are also moments of that meal that
are just so, like purification level of this
really, really, really delicious things put
together, like that egg yolk sauce with a
little bit of rice left in the bottom of the
bowl.
Wow. But I don't want to discount the amount
of work that chef has put into understanding
an older form of sushi upon which he is
building sushi.
What? So what the hell is going on?
What the hell is that?
Look at this. I don't know if you guys can
see it.
It's like a sunset, of tuna.
Chef Udatsu:
One bite.
I will try.
Lucas:
I could try to say something poetic, like,
oh, this is the bite that encapsulates all
these other bites that preceded it, but that
is just I mean, that's a ridiculous thing.
You can't not experience that to know what
that feels like.
Oh.
Wow. What a climax.
Oh, hey. Whoa.
That's got plenty of fish in it, but it
teases out all that sweetness.
It's fun. And it's funny.
Egg for dessert. Like this. Very good.
I think I need a moment to process this.
The best tasting menus feel like a journey,
because not only have you gone from point A
to point B like you've physically moved, but
then you can look back at every single slice
of that experience and remember it and
reflect on it and feel like it all
accumulated to something like A plus B, plus
C, and it all like maximized into this big
thing. And that's my feeling, especially
with that last Maguro Futomaki and then the
the Tamago.
Thank you.
On this list, there are two things that it
asks of me.
One is to have a Zen moment, and the second
is to write a haiku about my experience with
my utter lack of command of the Japanese
language and a little bit of help from our
friendly crew members.
I present to you the following.
That's pretty good. Five.
Seven. Five. Done.
The takeaway I think from today is that there
is no sense of progress without deep
understanding of tradition.
And Udatsu Sushi is a shining example of
that.
At the end of the meal, chef and I had a
drink at the bar next door at Bar Rokusho.
Cheers.
Chef Udatsu:
Thank you very much.
Lucas:
Thank you. How do you feel?
After cooking like that.
I bet if I was cooking all day, and this guy
made me keep talking about the philosophy of
food, I just want to, like, "shut up.
Can we talk about baseball or something?"
You know.
Chef Udatsu:
Finish. Yeah.
Just drink.
Lucas:
Done.